long before I was born he came as the
spearhead of an alien invasion
which means you
like all the others
please we have families what does
everyone keep telling me there are
enemies coming from far away
I need warrior
[Music]
just like that you really are out of
your mind I'm not the one who brought a
pitchfork
[Music]
I don't recognize this way
dirty miser
we just have to save it
ride ain't over yet not man
[Music]
what did you do this weekend Diana
nothing very interesting
warrior of the
daughter of Zeus
and protector of the world she grew up
isolated from the world of men to super
smart super sophisticated full of hope
she's the most talented warrior but it
time doesn't care for the fame or for
the glory she partners with Batman to
unite the need we're asking people we
don't know to risk their lives
I know so this works she's this glue to
the team she makes each and every one of
them feel stronger and capable
he said the age of heroes who never come
again
[Music]
to the end of the world
you can't save the world amount we do
this together
all in
[Music]
hey everybody surprised we got even more
new Justice League people are calling
this the final trailer I don't know if
it will be the actual last trailer
because we're not getting the movie for
a couple more weeks so there might be
some more footage dropping between now
and then they're also screening the
movie for Chinese critics and doing
Chinese press this week so people have
already started posting early reaction
videos so I included that at the end of
this too but there is a new round of the
ticket giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video this is probably one of my
favorite images from this I feel like
they could actually do this on the TV
shows with Oliver and Barry at some
point but just imagine the conversation
that flash has with Batman like Batman
wouldn't want to do something like this
he just goes into battle flash is one of
those people who would probably think
about composition in the battle like oh
if I come down behind him like this it
looks super cool but you have to imagine
that like up behind them here Batman is
swinging off the flying box and flash is
coming down to the ground but the real
big difference with this trailer is that
it's mostly hyping up Steppenwolf and
you get a much better look at him than
we pad before where Wonder Woman
narrates that big war that they had
before she was born he was spearheading
this alien invasion long before I ever
came along that you see the Amazons you
see a version of him boom tubing in in
the Amazons rushing the battlefield
later in the trailer when you see all
these apocalyptic ships coming in it's a
little hard to tell if this is happening
in that flashback scene or in present
day because all the footage we've seen
of Steppenwolf in present day seems like
it's him boom tubing into that mascara
taking all the Amazons asses and then
making his way to the next mother boxes
as he builds this nest of parademons
with his big lava axe but I think part
of the idea is is that he did the exact
same thing in this flashback scene as
he's doing in present day like what you
see the red skies you see all these pair
of demons you see this underground lair
that he comes back with a vengeance and
the actors that plays Steppenwolf
actually explained a little bit about
his relationship with Darkseid there
were some confusion about it previously
if he's going to be the uncle like it's
in the comics or if Darkseid's going to
be his uncle so in the comics
Steppenwolf has always been
Darkseid's uncle but Darkseid has always
been more powerful so Steppenwolf always
has this weird
relationship with him where he has to
serve him because he doesn't want to die
but he's not super happy about it so the
way he explained his Justice League
character is that he's ancient way older
than Darkseid he hates him with a
passion and wants to find a way to free
himself from servitude to his nephew so
that's where the mother box has come in
so they're slowly trying to convert the
earth into another version of apocalypse
just like convert everybody to
parademons so I think he's hoping to
build an army big enough to take on
Darkseid himself so everybody hates
Darkseid the Justice League hasn't even
met Darkseid yet they hate him
Steppenwolf and the rest of the elite
probably don't like him that much either
he's just so powerful that you have to
do what he wants but you can kind of
tell how they're hyping up the Wonder
Woman in this too you never thought that
there would be so much lasso based
comedy this year but I feel like it
works really really well so I'm actually
so happy that the Wonder Woman movie
turned out the way it did because now
they have a place to build from and even
though they're mostly working on
developing Wonder Woman - just because
the first movie was so successful I
really want to see patty Jenkins take a
crack at the next Man of Steel movie I
feel like she could make a really good
Superman movie if you didn't see the
Easter egg videos I did she took direct
inspiration from a lot of the richer
daughter Superman films so a lot of
Wonder Woman is in the tone of
Christopher Reeve Superman so I feel
like she really understands his
character it'll be interesting to see
what their plans are for Superman in the
future they tentatively have a Man of
Steel sequel on the schedule for
somewhere around 2020 but there's no
hard date on that I think Henry Cavill
will continue to be Superman in the way
that Joe Manganiello was kind of in a
Deathstroke holding pattern for a while
and now they're making a Deathstroke
spin-off film finally so if you weren't
sure about it they are writing the
second Justice League movie right now
they have no idea when it's going to be
released I think it just depends on how
well this first Justice League movie
does as long as it performs within their
expectations I think they'll try to get
it out in the next two to three years
maybe three years at the most you look
at the way Marvel schedules its Avengers
films usually it's every two years but I
think they might slide - every three
years depending on how well their
spin-off movies do in the future like
Marvel phase 4 stuff you may have seen
that they're doing all this press and
right now they're premiering the movie
there so you'll probably start hearing
about the early reviews so far they've
been largely positive the movies a
little under two hour is like an hour
and 59 minutes so it'll be interesting
to talk about what we think that they
changed and what people confirmed from
behind the scenes because I have a
feeling that they shot like four hours
of movie it along the way there were
various reports about how the movie was
going to be over two and a half hours
long like this was supposed to be even
bigger than Batman V Superman so I think
the expectation was is that it would be
a super long movie but I think they
probably chose wisely in trying to cut a
lot of the extra stuff out just to
simplify and focus on the main
characters so after everybody gets a
chance to see it we can talk about what
we think they cut out when I start
posting Easter Egg videos but that'll be
once the movie premieres in the United
States I think I'm allowed to post my
non-spoilery review right before the
release date whenever the embargoes up
so as soon as that happens I'll post my
first review video but like I said
people in China have already started to
post their reviews so far they've been
largely positive so I think that most
people will be pleasantly surprised but
just be careful not to set your
expectations too high when you go in
it'll be a fun movie like Thor Ragnarok
is it ninety-eight percent on Rotten
Tomatoes right now but once everybody
sees it that number will come down just
a little bit like I think the Wonder
Woman movies started out at 98 percent
on Rotten Tomatoes and I think right now
after like hundreds and hundreds of
people have reviewed it it's settled
down to like 92 or 94 percent it's still
crazy high so once you do have a chance
to see the movie just post all your
reactions in the comments just please no
spoilers on this particular video just
wait till I post my spoiler review
videos for that but because there's so
much stuff happening tonight I'll try to
get my next Avengers video out before my
arrow episode tonight but there is arrow
tonight I'll announce the new ticket
giveaway winner when I post that you can
click here to watch some of the gods
like Zeus from the Wonder Woman movie
fight in that first big Darkseid war and
you can click here for brand new flash
footage thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome
I'll see you
guys tonight